رافائيل بولوك هو جراح سرطان ،
لكنه أيضًا مريض بالسرطان يكافح أحد
أشكال سرطان الدم ، يعتبر خطر الإصابة بفيروس كوفيد -19
مرتفعًا بعد أن أكملت
لقطتي التطعيم في فبراير من
هذا العام ،
وقد تم فحص مستويات الأجسام المضادة الخاصة بي
وكان
رد الفعل شديدًا ولكن بعد ستة أشهر  لقد
قمت بفحصهم مرة أخرى ولم
يعد من الممكن اكتشافهم منذ ذلك الحين ، بقي بولوك في
المنزل لحماية صحته ، لكن في يوم
الأربعاء انضم إلى مرضى آخرين في مركز السرطان
الشامل بجامعة أوهايو الحكومية
وقام بلف جعبته
للمرة الثالثة وأود أن
أحصل على خط العرض  أن أكون قادرًا على الذهاب إلى
متجر البقالة بدلاً من الاعتماد على
أطفالي للقيام بذلك
أو حتى مجرد التنزه في الحديقة
ولا أشعر أنني قد أواجه
شيئًا قد يكون خطيرًا بالنسبة لي ،
معظم الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم معرضين لخطر الإصابة بالسرطان
لم يتوقف المرضى أبدًا عن
التفكير في مخاطر التكيف معهم. 19. يقول الدكتور ديفيد
كوهن كبير المسؤولين الطبيين في المركز
إن جرعة إضافية من اللقاح أمر
بالغ الأهمية لأنه  قد لا يكون الأشخاص الذين يعانون من نقص المناعة
قد حصلوا على استجابة مناعية كافية
مع لقاحين فقط من لقاح mrna ، فإن
الأشخاص داخل جهاز المناعة الضعيف
لديهم مخاطر أعلى للإصابة بالطمع أو للإصابة
بمرض شديد إذا
أصيبوا بفيروس كوفيد أو يموتون
من تلك العدوى وهذا هو السبب في أن بولوك
هو  ممتنًا للحلقة الثالثة ، فهو يخطط
لإجراء اختبار للأجسام المضادة مرة أخرى
في غضون أسبوعين ، ونأمل
أن يظهروا أنني استجبت جيدًا
للحظة الصحية.